في مثل هذه الاحوال الماساويه عاده ما
يتبادر الى الاذهان الاجراءات التي يجب
اتباعها في مثل هذه الحالات ويبدو ان هناك
الكثير من سبل الحمايه في مثل هذه الاوقات
منها ما هو قبل الهزه كتحديد اماكن امنه
في الخارج بعيدا عن الابنيه والاشجار وعدم
التوجه الى المناطق الساحليه خوفا من حدوث
موجات مد عاتيه اما اثناء الهزه فلا تبادر
الى الخروج او النزول الى الملجا فالبقاء
في الداخل اسلم ابتعد عن النوافذ واحمل
راس والوجه بما امكن وفي حال كان الشخص
خارج المنزل وفي السياره يجب ركن السياره
بعيدا عن المباني والامدادات الكهربائيه
العامه وعدم عبور الجسور ودخول الانفاق
اما بعد حصول الهزه فاذا كنت مصابا حافظ
على هدوئك وتجنب صدمات الخوف والهلع واذا
لم تتعرض لاي اصابه اخمد الصغيره واقطع
جميع مصادر الطاقه واستعد لحدوث هزات
ارتداديه قبل حدوثها
[موسيقى]
احيانا النظريات صعب تطبيقها اثناء
الفاجعه والكارثه والمصيبه عندما تحل ولكن
هل يمكن الحديث عن طريقه مثلى طريقه صحيحه
يمكن ان نحمي بها انفسنا في حال وقوع
الزلازل كما تفضلتي اخت نادين هنالك
الاجراءات الوقائيه التي يمكن ان يقوم بها
الشخص قبل حدوث الزلزال واثناء الزلزال
وبعد الزلزال اذا كان في داخل البيت او في
خارج البيت
فكما تفضلتي قبل الزلزال طبعا الزلزال
يحدث على مدى فترات قد مثلا زلزال في
تركيا الان استمر لمده دقيقتين فخلال هذه
المده يعني يجب الانسان الواعي فيتطلب من
الجهات المدنيه والجهات في كل بلده ان
تثقف الناس على ماذا يفعلون والاسعافات
الاوليه اثناء مواجهه هذه الكوارث اولا في
حال حدوث الزلزال هل يجب ان ابقى مكاني
اذا كنت في المنزل ومع الاسف الذي يعني
قدر الله سبحانه وتعالى ان الزلزال كان في
الوقت الصباح الباكر فمعظم الناس كانوا
راقدين
والزلزال استغرق حوالي دقيقتين فمثلا لو
كان هناك والشخص في المنازل معظم الناس
كانوا في المنازل او الانخفاض والاحتماء
بالسرير كمثل ان يحتمل انسان تحت منضده او
الى لم يوجد منضده يحتمي
بشيء صلب لا يقع عليه وان لم يجد فيحتمي
بنفسه اي يعني يضم يديه
وينزل راسه ويبتعد عن الزجاج والنوافذ قدم
الاستطاعه لان هذه كلها تحدث على على يعني
فكرات قصيره يعني اذا كان في السرير فيبقى
في مكانه ويحتمي ولو بوساده
لا يقف عند المداخن المداخل الابواب الا
يعني يتاكد انها قويه يعني مسلحه وليست من
المباني
نعم انا خارج المنزل مثلا في الشارع وفي
السياره ماذا يجب علينا ان نفعل
اذا طبعا في الخارج اذا كنت تقودين
السياره ام كنت ماشيه ماشيه فاذا كنت يعني
في الخارج اول شيء الشخص يتحرك بعيد عن
المباني وعن الاعمده والاسلاك الكهربائيه
ويقف ولا يتحرك حتى تنتهي الهزه الارضيه
هذا اذا كان ماشيا اما اذا كان يقود
السياره فافضل شيء ان يتوقف في منطقه
نائيه بعيده عن المباني ويظل في السياره
ويظل في السياره ويتجنب الوقوف بالقب او
من اسفل المباني ويبتعد عن الجسور لان
الجسور وهو في السياره هي جسور طبعا اثناء
الزلزال تتحرك قواعد الجسور ويؤدي الى
سقوط الجسر لا سمح الله
فيبتعد عن هذا ويقف جانبا في مكان يعني
امن وينتظر ويدعو الله سبحانه وتعالى ان
يفرج هذه
[موسيقى]